how has life been in quarantine what
have you been up to
oh i'm uh i'm here in the kentucky
mountains
i've been here for two and a half months
now i have a lodge here that normally
it holds about 28 people a night and
it's it's uh
usually booked up solid with hikers and
yoga retreats and rock climbers
oh i'm jealous that sounds awesome
it's definitely helped uh keep my sanity
a little bit
well when i say what have you been up to
you've been very busy
i know that your new album is out on may
29th which i can only imagine
is so exciting for you how pumped are
you for the fans to hear
wildwood i mean i've been working on
this project for the last
year and a half
[Music]
this has been hands down the most uh
that i feel like people have
really digested the lyrics this much
um this is the heaviest i would heaviest
hitting lyrically i feel like of all the
record way fans have reacted to the
first three songs it's probably the most
anticipated project
i've ever had so i'm i'm super excited
for people to get to hear it as a whole
[Music]
why do you think it is so important for
people to to hold on to
music to get through a timeline well i
mean i just feel like there's a definite
um heaviness in the air of
a lot of people having fear right now
and i think that music provides
an escape and i think that it also
provides a chance to actually
face some of the things that you might
be dealing with internally
and be able to relate to something that
you hear and be able to process
those thoughts
[Music]
i know something you're very passionate
about is kip's kids fund
so tell me about this foundation and i
believe i read recently you were able to
provide meals for
3 000 children in nashville yeah
that was just um i made a call into a
company called eat well nashville
this is amazing company that i i get a
lot of meals from when i hit the road i
just
called them up i was like is there
something we might can do can i maybe
buy a bunch of meals from you guys
and get out and start delivering these
meals into the communities where these
kids were
relying on school lunches i can only
imagine for you being able to help so
many people during this time that's
awesome
we should always have that that mindset
of
not needing someone to ask us for help
but when you notice it
try to do something about it
you